WAY TO REBUILD IN FLORIDA AFTER
HURRICANE IAN DECIMATED ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THOUSANDS ARE STILL WITHOUT
POWER.
BUT ONE COMMUNITY HIT DIRECTLY
BY THE STORM CAME OUT WITH
BARELY A SCRATCH.
CNN'S BILL WEIR HAS THE STORY.
>> Reporter: WHEN HURRICANE IAN
BROUGHT GUSTS OVER 150 MILES AN
HOUR, MUCH OF THE POWER GRID IN
ITS PATH DID NOT STAND A CHANCE.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> Reporter: AND AND THAT'S TO
TWO FEET OF RAIN, EVEN
COMMUNITIES MILES FROM THE SURGE
COULD NOT AVOID FLOODS.
AND WHILE THIS HAPPENED, ANTHONY
WAS SITTING AT HOME WATCHING TV.
>> I SAID TO MY WIFE, I DON'T
HAVE ANY FEAR RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: ANTHONY AND THE
FAMILIES AROUND HIM DID NOT LOSE
POWER AND DID NOT FLOOD BECAUSE
THEY LIVE IN BABCOCK RANCH, A
COMMUNITY ABOUT 15 MILES FROM
FORT MYERS, WHICH IS 100% SOLAR
POWERED.
>> I EVEN HELD ON TO MY
GENERATOR BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
MY WIFE WAS LIKE "GET RID OF IT"
AND I SAID, NO.
THIS WAS THE TEST.
>> Reporter: NOW YOU CAN GET RID
OF THE GENERATOR?
>> I GAVE IT TO A FRIEND.
>> Reporter: WITH A Ph.D IN
CIVIL ENGINEERING, SHE HELPED
DESIGN THIS PLACE.
>> I GOT MY CONSTRUCTION DRAWING
OUT AND I LOOKED AT THE FLORIDA
ELEVATION AND THE ROAD ELEVATION
AND I MENTALLY WAS CRUNCHING
NUMBERS BECAUSE I WAS LIKE THIS
IS GOING TO BE BAD.
>> Reporter: AND IT WAS.
BUT THEIR INTERCONNECTED LAKES
AND PROTECTED WETLANDS SAVED
THEM FROM FLOODING AND THE
700,000 SOLAR PANELS IN THEIR
150 MEGA WATT ARRAY ALL HELD
SOLID.
>> I ALWAYS ASSUMED THAT SOLAR
PANELS AND HURRICANES DON'T MIX,
THAT IT WOULD TURN THEM INTO
PROJECTILES, BUT YOU DIDN'T LOSE
ANY?
>> THAT'S THE BEAUTIFUL THING
ABOUT ENGINEERING, RIGHT, IS
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THE WIND
LOADS AND YOU UNDERSTAND THE
STRESS AND THE STRAIN AND YOU
DESIGN TO THAT.
>> Reporter: THIS PLACE IS THE
BRAIN CHILD OF AN NFL OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN TURNED DEVELOPER, WHO
BOUGHT A MASSIVE CATTLE RANCH,
SOLD MOST TO FLORIDA AS A NATURE
PRESERVE AND SET OUT TO BUILD
THE CLEANEST, MOST RESILIENT
TOWN IN AMERICA.
>> HERE'S THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
WE HAVE A FIELD HOUSE OVER THERE
WHICH IS NOW HOUSING PEOPLE AS A
SHELTER.
>> Reporter: I GUESS IT'S
FITTING THAT THE MASCOT OF
BABCOCK HIGH ARE THE TRAIL
BLAZERS.
>> EVERYTHING'S VERY WELL
THOUGHT OUT HERE.
>> I GOT TO SAY I FEEL A LITTLE
GUILTY LEAVING DAMAGE BUT IT'S A
RELIEF TO COME TO A PLACE
UNSCATHED.
>> WE'RE FEELING GUILD, TOO.
>> Reporter: REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> I FEEL RELIEVED THAT WE'RE
NOT ADDING TO WHAT FIRST
RESPONDERS HAVE TO DEAL WITH AND
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY.
SO WE HAVE PEOPLE HERE MAKING
MEALS OR TAKING IN LAUNDRY FROM
SHERIFFS AND FIREFIGHTERS THAT
ARE IN FROM OUT OF TOWN BECAUSE
WE WERE RESILIENT, BECAUSE WE
WERE DURABLE, WE'RE ABLE TO HELP
IN THAT WAY.
>> HERE'S THE TEST OF BATTERIES.
NEVER HAD TO USE THEM.
>> Reporter: FOR THOSE WHO SAY
IF YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A
SUSTAINABLE LIFESTYLE YOU HAVE
TO LIVE IN A YURT AND EAT STRAW,
THIS IS A COUNTER TO THAT.
YOU'RE NOT LACKING FOR COMFORT.
>> NO, IN THE 21st CENTURY, YOU
DON'T NEED TO DO THAT.
IT'S HERE, THE TECHNOLOGY IS
HERE.
WE JUST NEED TO GET EVERYBODY ON
BOARD AND MAKE IT AFFORDABLE FOR
EVERYBODY TO GET ON BOARD.
>> AND BILL WEIR JOINS US NOW
LIVE FROM NAPLES, WHICH LOOKS
VERY DIFFERENT, BILL, THAN THAT
COMMUNITY WHERE YOU WERE JUST
IN.
AND IT'S, WHAT, A DOZEN MILES
AWAY FROM FORT MYERS?
>> Reporter: EXACTLY, JOHN.
AND THEY REALLY WANT TO BE A
MODEL.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE
INTERVIEWS AND TOOTING HIS HORN
WHILE THERE'S SO MUCH PAIN GOING
ON RIGHT NOW WHEN.
HE WENT TO FLORIDA POWER AND
LIGHT AND SAY I WANT TO BUILD
THIS SOLAR CITY, THEY SAY, I
DON'T KNOW, YOU'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO HAVE TO GIVE US THE
LAND SO THE COST DOESN'T GO TO
CUSTOMERS.
THE PRICE OF THE PANELS HAD FALL
I DON'T KNOW SO FAR, HE DIDN'T
HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE LAND.
SO IT'S HARD TO FIND STORIES OF
HOPE AND SOLUTIONS IN THE MIDDLE
OF ALL OF THIS MISERY BUT THIS
IS PROOF THAT YOU CAN LIVE THE
FLORIDA DREAM AND ST